but we begin with broadsides from Team
Trump after the outlandish revelations
in the inspector general's report on the
Clinton email investigation starting
with President Trump shot at the FBI
brass in chief he then the chief he
fired of course Jim Comey on Fox and
Friends this morning the president took
a swipe at what he called the scum at
the top of the bureau under obama the IG
report came out yesterday the FBI looks
bad very bad
yeah well no it says Comey I mean they
were talking about Comey not my FBI was
telling me the people in the FBI are
incredible I would bet if you took a
poll in the FBI I would win that poll by
more than anybody's ever won appalled
but the top people were horrible you
look at what happened they were plotting
against my election presidential
attorney Rudy Giuliani said it's Comey
who should be investigated and that the
FBI agent should be quote fired today
and in prison next week let's
investigate the investigators let's take
a halt to the Muller investigation let's
stop and let's turn it and get rid of
all the agents doing the Muller
investigation the reality is did
something like that obviously shouldn't
be worked the FBI he's got emotional
problems and probably needs valium or
something like that
Giuliani was referring to Peter struck
the FBI agent who vowed to stop Trump
from becoming president and a text
uncovered in the IG report struck is now
facing his own day of reckoning as house
judiciary chair Bob Goodlatte has begun
proceedings to subpoena him struck was
the lead FBI agent remember in the
Clinton email probe a top agent in the
FBI's Russia probe and the agent who
interviewed former national security
adviser Mike Flynn he then became a top
investigator in Special Counsel Bob
Muller's Russia probe all that ended of
course when Struck's bombastic
anti-trump text with his lover FBI
attorney lisa page were revealed struck
was demoted to the FBI's HR department
that's ironic which raises the question
why the heck is he still working at the
FBI especially in light of the text
message revealed yesterday
where he vowed to stop Trump from
becoming president
joining me now our former FBI national
spokesperson and special agent John in
ireli attorney and RNC committee woman
from California Harmeet Dillon and
former assistant attorney general robert
Driscoll all right I want to start with
you Bob on this because it's fascinating
to me how when you survey the other
networks over the last 24 hours
it mean it was like andhe stormy Daniels
they've spent precious little time on
this
oh no evidence of bias this is like this
is a big nothing burger I'm so sick of
that word by the way but let's remember
what Horowitz did conclude and this is
important departing so clearly and
dramatically from FBI and Department
norms the decisions negatively impacted
the perception of the FBI and the
department as fair administrators of
Justice Robert fair administrators of
Justice now with a Russia collusion
probe gone on for more than a year about
18 million dollars it's cost apparently
with no end in sight well I mean the
damage has been done and I think this
report makes it clear that there was a
but there's rampant bias within the FBI
and levels of the DOJ and it's clear in
the report all the report says and I
think people take this sentence out of
context the report said that that
Horowitz couldn't link the examples of
bias to any particular investigative
decision which of course he couldn't no
one generally writes down when they're
you know doing something that improper
but he found bias and it's you know
through all 500 pages on each page
there's more examples of bias and one
text message or email is worse than the
next and so the bias is there is just a
question if he took a very broad view of
essentially of any investigative
decision was defensible not proper but
just defensible he he passed on it so
and I think it it really is to me
shockingly bad but the the breadth of
the report and that the the breadth of
the of the bias and corruption was I
mean I think shocking harm II Peter
struck is too
collecting a taxpayer-funded salary
which I mean I can't believe he's still
working and of all places in human
resources I mean that just like takes
the cake you can't write how stupid that
is but it looks like Bob Goodlatte does
want him to testify on Capitol Hill
apparently he's wanted to talk to him
for over a year and he's begun the
process reportedly of getting that
subpoena takes two days I guess the
process takes about two days but he
wants that he wants struck up on Capitol
Hill and he wants information and he
wants it like yesterday
right and the question is when you read
this shocking oh I GE report why he's
had this job for so long struck and you
know ray who the president was praising
in his tweets you know why they haven't
done something about this already you
know there was evidence of bias we see
the shocking instance of the text that
he sent back to his lover about how he
wasn't going to let Trump become the
president and and that was withheld from
Congress so when you when you read this
report you can't help feel like number
one obviously it's a very thorough
report and goes into a lot of the
shocking bias but the conclusion is well
you know we can't treat we don't have a
smoking gun so we can't do anything
about it that's the problem all along
with an office of inspector general
investigation they don't have the power
to do anything about it it's more like
and after the fact HR you know internal
investigation as what we can do better
next time and that's not going to cut it
here but the damage that has been done
to our country and the damage isn't
being done with the Muller investigation
it requires stronger measures that's
simply an investigation into what went
wrong we've got to do something about it
John the damage to the FBI
I think cannot be overstated here we
have men and women who work so hard in
the field offices all across this
country day by day night by night to
keep Americans safe and do really great
investigative work this ended up being a
political Oppo research operation
against a you know ultimately against
the president with the Russia probe but
a see why a situation with Hillary
Clinton and these emails all along if
you actually read this report I've
gotten through most of it there is a lot
in this report that
press of course is conveniently glossing
over it you're right the fact of the
matter is that some horrible things were
done that should have never occurred and
we have to keep in the context so
remember this is a group of individuals
who knew each other some were
hand-picked by their friends to work in
this project if you will
meanwhile you have 35,000 FBI employees
doing good things every day and not
acting by ously I think it's important
that they need to come clean here and
you're right whether or not mr. struck
should still be working at FBI
headquarters it's certainly a question a
lot of us are asking now remember guys
as we said the IG did not say he found
no bias at the FBI he said that there
was no documentary evidence that bias
produced specific decisions yeah we
gotta remember it is another IG report
coming down the pike you call it IG 2.0
if you want and that could end up being
loaded with evidence of such bias
because that's about the looking into
the informants that were used in the
Trump campaign and maybe these potential
FISA abuses the FBI handling of the
Russia probe so I want to go back to you
Bob
thinking that the IG again Horowitz
Trump was kind of annoyed today he said
there's a lot of good stuff there's
anything he kind of painted out at the
end that's that's what Donald Trump said
but this other I think this other report
could be really important in seeing what
happened to place individuals or
encourage individuals to try to
penetrate these lower-level people
inside the campaign well I think you'd
be important for two reasons I mean one
is what you talked about we'll find the
basis for this Russian investigation
whether or not it was the dossier
originally whether or not it was an
opposition research generated
investigation totally or not but more
importantly we'll be able to lay it
side-by-side with the IG report that
just came out because it will provide
some context so I mean in the Clinton
investigation we have the Clinton IT guy
getting granted immunity for essentially
nothing admitting that they destroyed
the emails after they're already under
subpoena no prosecution Cheryl Mills
being in the interview with Hillary
Clinton is both a witness and a lawyer
Huma Abedin Lodge sit in on the
hillarie interview I mean all those
things you know may be defensible
individually in a vacuum but an
incredibly light touch for anyone who's
ever gone through an FBI investigation
and then will gets to compare that and
you know 2.0 to gee what do you know
people's houses are being searched at
6:00 in the morning everyone's being
charged with false statements whether or
not they're material to any given crime
and so I think the second report could
have you know could be a big deal
because could fill in some of these gaps
or at least allow us to draw some
inferences yeah I mean guys there
certainly were very zealous in trying to
like find this evidence of Russia
working with trompe I mean getting this
professor in London talked to Pappa Dafa
it's like all the stuff that they were
trying to do my goodness they're like
leaving no stone unturned trying to get
a Russian billionaire to help that Oleg
Deripaska I mean they're doing
everything mean what with Hilary's like
well maybe we shouldn't maybe we
shouldn't get the lab the Weiner laptop
maybe we should wait on that so a
totally different approach which also I
think comes through when you really read
the totality of this report Harmeet
Giuliani today talked about the question
we've been talking about for months here
about whether the president should
testify I want you all to listen
carefully to this what you think should
happen now on the Moller investigation
that should end it I mean the IG report
basically tells you that both both both
prongs of the Moller investigation are
either corrupt or or answered he went on
to say the president should not he
basically said no interview the
president he shouldn't be bothered with
it
Harmeet any thinking of yours that's
changed from the beginning of a possible
perjury trap for a president who I mean
President Trump likes to talk he's he's
very affable he loves to get his point
across he didn't do anything wrong he
says so he's like I'm happy to talk he
wants to talk but as a lawyer and not a
lawyer as well how dangerous is it for
him to go into that special counsel's
office okay Laura so as to the first
part of your question does it change
anything no I from day one I thought the
president shouldn't talk you and I both
know that federal prosecutors are not
just you know regular prosecutors
they're they're the Gunners you know
they're the go-getters they're the ones
who want to make their case and make
their name there's no bigger prey than
the President of the United States so he
should not go in there because there's
no confidence that the stack the deck
won't be stacked against him we've seen
that with Flynn we've seen that how
struck has behaved in many other
instances yeah you know but in terms of
witnesses a CEO a powerful person is the
worst witness anybody can tell you
they're the worst witness because
they're used to getting their way
everybody in the room sucks up to them
and it's just a totally different
scenario when you're talking even
seemingly casually to a prosecutor or an
FBI agent so it would be a big mistake
for for any CEO for any president but
particularly for this president this is
going through a legal showdown
now we've seen the day option pervading
Giuliani's point was Giuliani's point
today was now that we've seen we know
just what was going on in there with the
with the desperate effort to stop him
from becoming president Cheryl Mills
gets to sit in there when they're
talking about whether they should
subpoena Hillary although you know the
cozy relationship between the press and
the FBI agents the press are getting a
are giving perks to the FBI agents they
don't know where these leaks came from
it's totally out of control and I want
to go back to you John corrupt because
because we have John Dow to exclusively
gave us a comment tonight about what
this IG report actually says he said the
clear evidence on that former of course
lead counsel for Trump the clear
evidence of his usurpation of power
violation of his oath of office and
material false statements to the public
in Congress all to conceal his own
misconduct warranted a criminal referral
of commis conduct the finding of no bias
was ludicrous the OIG is finding finding
support the president's decision to fire
call me John absolutely Comey was fired
because of the things that he had done
and the president was right to step
forward and take those actions I also
think a lot of things have been made out
of the fact that the president fired a
director of the FBI it's not
unprecedented we talked with William
sessions back in the early 90s where he
was fired by a
president President Clinton there were
firings of FBI directors before then but
this is clearly based under a report
we're seeing gives good cause and
justification for the actions the
president took then the guys there was
also the shocking development today a
federal judge appointed by Obama
actually jailed Paul Manafort
after Muller claimed he tried to tamper
with witnesses and shortly thereafter
Rudy Giuliani responded by floating the
idea of presidential pardons in the
Russia investigation
Robert this led this led Jeffrey Toobin
to say the following about Giuliani
let's watch it is so corrupt and
unethical what what Giuliani said I mean
you know we are in an area here that is
literally unprecedented because not that
many people in American life have the
power to give a pardon I mean you know
we are so far out of normal ethical
behavior that you know it's just worth
preserving our sense of outrage about it
because so much of this stuff happens
every day we're kind of ignored to it
but it really is a pall sense of outrage
jeffrey toobin that outrage during
Benghazi fast and furious but
surveilling reporters check in Cheryl
adkison's computer robert and
nevertheless the throwing out the pardon
thing I probably wouldn't have done that
if I were Rudy today it just it just
chums the water for no real reason well
and the other reason too is you know
just strategically as a defense lawyer
I wouldn't want Manta Ford pardoned
before this case is over because once
he's pardoned his Fifth Amendment right
against self-incrimination likely goes
away and so you know if he is pardoned
he no longer faces criminal prosecution
you know he would be he could
conceivably be forced to testify and
moreover it's just no reason to handle
it now you just wait and see where the
chips fall and if at some point later
the president wants to part and he can
and as far as it being unprecedented I
mean George Bush Senior pardoned cap
Weinberger the day of his trial I think
it was the day before his trial I
remember so I mean it's been done is
there's no question there is a in
power the president has to the partn bar
is one of the few absolutes the
president has and there's no real check
on it so I don't yeah I just can't get
that outrage oh the the the answer to it
is a political answer which is done
publicly and the president can suffer
blowback for it if he does it yeah I
mean close it out for us because the all
this is always conjuring up this sense
of moral outrage and we had a myriad of
instances where the Obama Justice
Department Eric Holder held in contempt
of Congress over the documents and I
think it was fast and furious I mean all
these things how gets out Carmack
meeting there's no moral outrage
suddenly Oh or outrage every two but in
CNS outrage over a discussion of pardon
it give me a break you know somebody
needs to give him the smelling salts the
you know the selective outrage is the
the hypocrisy is is is is laughable you
know they should be very concerned as
Americans about the pervasive corruption
of the FBI and other agencies in the
government and and not about this one
instance I'm outraged as a civil
libertarian that a judge is appearing to
use incarceration as a as a as a penalty
as a punishment for somebody prior to
their trial and we know that it's
actually only supposed to be used
preventative attention and very limited
circumstances where it deals with flight
risk or other issues and I don't think
that today she was really lecturing mana
for today saying you know you're not
basically you're not in junior high
can't take away your cell phone but
can't trust you not to talk to witnesses
so goodbye thank you all fantastic panel